et l'on conclura ce journal par un
hommage à une petite très grande dame de
la chanson edith piaf elle est morte il
ya trente ans les cérémonies souvenir ce
succès depuis 24 heures parfois solennel
soit nostalgique mais un hommage va-t-il
être nécessairement triste pascal d'où
ces bons hervé pozzo était hier soir
villejuif dans le val-de-marne
bien sûr il ya des dizaines de façons de
chanter bien
il ya d'abord le style chanteur de rue
classique et de boue
une noire avec la neige on peut aussi
adopter un mode plus bondissant du genre
mais l'électrique qui semer la terreur
on peut encore sortir des sentiers
battus piaf nique mais de la môme on
peut aussi conserver la force et la rage
et ça c'est loin d'être facile
ils essaient ne pas tomber dans
l'imitation s'approprier la chanson et
et d'aller aussi loin possible
lavialle ça se trouve dans nos labos
l'amour ça se perd dans la on a aussi le
droit de chantonnay sur un
accompagnement minimaliste en tout cas
ce qui compte c'est le coeur et rien
d'autre c'est pas forcément triste parce
qu'on aimait dans la rue on est
forcément prise moi je crois au
contraire très populaire on est nous on
est populaire il ya un trou
enfin
quant aux clowneries elles sont
recommandées c'est bon pour le moral
même si ça fait déjà 30 ans qu'elle est
partie
si vous souhaitez la voir et l'arrêt
entente france 2 et europe 1 vous
propose sous forme de cassette l'unique
récital filmé et enregistré en public